في خطابه الاول بعد انتخابه لولايه ثالثه
مدتها خمس سنوات على راس الصين شدد الرئيس
الصيني على ضروره التعزيز الامن القومي في
كلمه القاها في ختام الدوره السنوي
البرلمان محذرا من المخاطر التي تتعارض
لها بلاده وقال نحو ثلاثه الاف نائب
تجمعوا في قصر الشعب في بكين قال ان الامن
هو اساس التنميه في حين ان الاستقرار شرط
اساسي للازدهار مؤكدا ضروره التعزيز
الكامل لعمليه تحديث الدفاع الوطني
والقوات المسلحه وجعل الجيش سورا فولابيا
عظيما يحمي سياده الوطنيه والامن ومصالح
التنميه على حد وصفه كما اتخذ زعيم الصيني
القوه الخارجيه التي تتدخل في تايوان
ان التنميه في الصين تفيد العالم ولا يمكن
للصين ايضا ان تتطور بمعزل عن بقيه العالم
وفي الوقت الذي نبذل فيه جهودا ملموسه
لتعزيز الانفتاح فاننا لن نزيد الاسواق
والموارد العالميه من اجل تنميهنا الخاصه
فحسب بل سنعمل ايضا على تعزيز تنميه
العالم باسره وسنكرس جهودنا للسلام
والتنميه والتعاون والمنفعه المتبادله
ونقف بحزم على الجانب الصحيح من التاريخ
ونمارس التعدديه الحقيقيه
واكد رئيس الصين على ان بلاده ستعمل على
تعزيز امنها القومي للحفاظ على استقارها
مشددا على ان بكين ستمضي قدما في حملتها
لتعبئه وستؤسس جيشا قويا ليحمي امنها
ومصالحها
الامن هو اساس التنميه والاستقرار هو
الشرط الاساسي للازدهار وعلينا تنفيذ نهج
شامل للامن القومي وتحسين نظام الامن
القومي لدينا وتعزيز قدرتنا على حمايه
الامن القومي وتعزيز اداره السلامه العامه
وكذلك تحسين نظام الحوكمه الاجتماعيه
لضمان نموذج انمائي جديد
يجب علينا المضي قدما في حملتنا للتعبئه
فيما يتعلق بالدفاع الوطني والجيش
وتحويل جيش الصين الى جدار كبير من الصلب